dr. strange is undeniably fun from start
to finish by introducing the mystic
Artes the multiverse and a whole lot of
Dormammu the benedict cumberbatch
starring superheroes sorceries story
keeps Marvel Studios streak alive into
the latter half of 2016 but it's not
perfect
call us nitpickers call us buzzkills
call us acolytes of the Dark Dimension
but we're about to dive into some of the
less magical aspects of dr. Strange's
plot while it's story is actually really
tight overall there are still a few
niggling plot holes and contrivances
that you can't simply wave away with the
wand of watoomb no matter how hard you
try oh and it should go without saying
but let's say the magic words anyway
massive spoilers ahead in security
system the movie begins with casillas
played by Mads Mikkelsen breaking into
the Ancient Ones library to steal a
couple of pages from one of her very
favorite books these books contain the
most advanced knowledge and spells in
the ancient ones possession they're
pretty important that must be why she
keeps them loosely draped in chains that
appear to be entirely decorative it goes
without saying that cassellius needs to
steal the pages describing the ritual
for the movie to you know actually
happen it wouldn't have taken much more
on the movies part to make it a little
harder for the bad guy to actually steal
them and hey while we're on that subject
why didn't castelia just take the whole
book course if that happened then the
book wouldn't be incredibly easy for our
hero Doctor Strange to take a look at
when he needed to learn about the
rituals later in the movie speaking of
which oh hey kuselias isn't it weird
that on the night that strange wanders
into the magic library when he reads
from the book with the missing ritual
page is stolen by Caelius when he
teaches himself how to use the
all-powerful eye of agamotto that can
manipulate time itself that's the very
night the very moment when the villain
decides to launch his attack on all
three magical sanctums including the
library itself not only that but it also
happens literally seconds after dr.
strange says that he won't be dragged
into some sort of mystical war that's
bad timing doc next time why don't you
try saying I got a bad feeling about
this
or maybe I don't know
market Inc yeah those words too must be
powerful spells that magically compel
the plot to move forward at the most
dramatic moment I owe my while we're on
the subject of that scene in the library
Wang and Mordo both seem pretty unhappy
about how strange went and started
messing with the eye of agamotto
the to tell him about all the terrible
consequences that could come from
monkeying with the timestream and then
they put the book back just one thing
though why didn't they take that big
honkin amulet off him too
oh so we can have it during the villain
fight that's about to take place for the
rest of the movie oh okay that's cool
no time to explain we hear a vague list
of consequences that the world might
possibly face as a result of strangest
experiments with the I like time loops
and alternate timelines or something
equally unspecified and hey we all saw
Back to the Future Part two nobody wants
v Hannon to take over the world and get
down with our moms but aside from the
time loops that were admittedly part of
the extremely clever and satisfying
climactic battle with or Mamu we never
actually learned anything concrete about
the dangers of screwing with time kind
of seems like there might be no actual
consequences at all despite Mordo
thinking that their dire enough to leave
the good guys and become a super villain
by the end but what was really so very
bad about using the AI to save the
entire planet from being sucked into the
Dark Dimension kung-fu cloak remember
that wacky magic carpet from Aladdin
that one that was so expressive and fun
despite not having a mouth or eyes or
even a face well that carpets back in
cloak form that's right
the cloak of levitation is the magical
item that takes a liking to the good
doctor and helps them in his battle
against kuselias and his goons in the
new york sanctum it's pretty handy
except when it isn't like when Doctor
Strange gets stabbed in the chest and
literally any other time after its
initial introduction the cloak seems to
have a mind of its own and acts as an
important ally for strange on his heroic
quest but only when it's convenient
otherwise just you know a cape but a
fancy looking cape to sanctums or three
we learn from Wang that there are three
sanctums protecting the world from evil
cassellius and his minions take down the
in London and destroy the one in Hong
Kong and that's when dormammu's Dark
Dimension starts to come through but the
New York sanctum is still standing so
how many of these things does the world
actually need follow-up appointment
regardless of whatever plot holes or
hiccups we think we may have found here
Doctor Strange was hugely fun when it
comes to an amazing introduction to the
weird magical side of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe one thing's for sure
the doctor is in thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel and watch more
videos like the one you just saw and
don't forget to check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to